I've met lots of people in my life with
obsessive-compulsive disorder and one of
the things that they've all said when
they talk about their affliction is that
they can't really explain why they keep
doing the rituals that they keep doing
whether it's turning on a light switch
turning it on and off three times before
leaving the house or having to be the
last one to say bye
during a phone call there is an element
of it that's beyond even their
explanation it's just sort of a
reflexive thing that they do or in the
case of OCD may be something that they
obsessively do would be a more
appropriate way to say it there's
something very similar going on with the
Republicans in the Senate and this
robert muller report they keep blocking
a resolution which would be non-binding
wouldn't even put a date certain as to
when the Moller report would have to be
released they keep trying to pass it
Democrats keep trying to pass it and
have passed it in the House and
Republicans now five times have blocked
it in the Senate and they either can't
or won't explain why it is that they're
blocking it they claim to be for
transparency they claim that the Moller
report totally clears the president they
claim that they're not worried about the
contents of the Moller report and yet
they have now for the fifth time blocked
the resolution to at some point release
the Moller report and when you ask them
why they don't even seem to know Mitch
McConnell has blocked this thing twice
at least already says he wants to give
William Barr time bogus reasoning
because the resolution gives William
Barr time it doesn't put a time date on
when the report has to be released a
Republican Lindsey Graham said he
blocked the resolution because he wants
more information about Hillary Clinton's
emails I'm not joking that that's the
reason why which makes no sense
whatsoever and he actually said quote
I'm making a political point by blocking
it Rand Paul when asked why he is
opposed to the release of the Moller
report says he wants an investigation
into how this Russia probe even started
in the first place which again is not a
reason to block the release of the
report if you want an investigation into
how the molar probes started which we
know by the way but let's pretend for a
second Rand Paul doesn't know that's a
reason to propose your own resolution
calling for that investigation if that's
what he wants it's not a reason to block
this resolution and once again I go back
to this question why not just play along
with this resolution it's non-binding it
doesn't put a specific timeline on when
the report has to be released it says
that things that would be prohibited by
law from being made public have to be
redacted so it doesn't prohibit all
redactions and there are a few different
reasons why we may be seeing Republicans
block this time and time and time again
the first is pretty obvious which is the
report actually is hugely damaging to
Donald Trump and they want to protect
Trump period pretty simple explanation a
possibility number two they're worried
that if redactions are made without a
legal basis in other words if the report
is released with a bunch of redactions
and some of those redactions were made
for political reasons not for legal
reasons those could be subject to
unredacted by Democrats through a
procedure that exists to do that that's
another possibility
another real possibility in terms of
what Republicans are doing here is that
maybe there's stuff in the Moller report
because it is more than 400 pages or
around 400 pages as we learned last week
maybe there's material in there that if
it's released closer to the 2020
election it could be damaging for
Republicans in their reelection
campaigns in the house or in the Senate
maybe they are exposed in some way and
what really doesn't sort of close for me
on this Pat is that throughout the
entire thing for two years the same
people who keep professing how innocent
they are are actively working to prevent
an investigation that supposedly would
find them innocent they are working to
prevent the release of a report which
supposedly vindicates them I've never
seen people who are so innocent that
working so hard to prevent the proof of
their innocence from getting out well I
think they certainly know that they're
not innocent and that this report won't
totally vindicate them
I mean they've had a couple weeks now to
workshop an answer that would be
suitable to the American public as to
why we can't release the Malheur report
and they've come up with zilch like you
know the classified information thing
that falls apart the Hillary's emails or
why we have to focus on the oranges or
the oranges of investigation that falls
apart too they're left with nothing here
there's no reason to block them all a
report we we are very close to the first
deadline on this thing the first
deadline is actually tomorrow I believe
and I'll be traveling to a conference in
Las Vegas if something breaks tomorrow
on this Ben Dixon is going to be here to
tell you about it otherwise I'll be back
on Wednesday or Thursday when will
likely have news about whether that
first deadline for the molars Mulla
reports release to Congress has been met
my prediction is it is not going to be
and if it is it will be just a comically
redacted version that is going to
immediately make Democrats say this
can't be the version that William bar
provides to us I think that this has a
lot of legs I think this is going to
continue being an issue for weeks if not
months and there are still no straight
answers from Republicans about what it
is that is going on here